here's Evan get a look at this so today
we're trying the least popular items at
McDonald's according to a quiz that we
did I'm Liz be calm are you jealous I
love McDonald's so I don't think I'm
gonna hate these items but if I do they
must really suck I love McDonald's Oh
like a place not really fast food you
can go to my dogs and just pick anything
off the menu you'll be it'll be good cuz
if you go to McDonald's you're expect
and you only have a certain expectation
this is the mushroom swiss burger and I
just gotta be honest and fun
I hate mush and I'm just assuming that
McDonald's does not have good mushrooms
what do you think just judging by Lux
looks fine to me looks uniform I hate
mushrooms really yeah smells good right
I'm on the fence
oh god this looks already a mushroom
falling out oh there's like some kind of
onion ring situation oh I'm down with
much yeah oh wait no no no no I'm down
with that onions and onions oh here's
dad you gotta look at this according to
our quiz only 3% of people picked this
as their most favorite that's 97% did
not like this
[Music]
your burger is nice all right ready
yeah never with Cheers
[Music]
cheers Cheers
they're not that okay I'm shockingly
like okay I'm gonna go I'm gonna be an
adult and have a bite that actually has
everything you can definitely taste the
mushrooms do the decimal sits in there
yeah you can taste the onions as well um
did I got bad back
it's got these little crispy onion
straws which I'm loving mmm wouldn't be
my first second third or fourth choice
definitely not I don't know that I would
swap out my regular order but I would
perhaps if I was drunk this I need this
I'd order this yeah who's right yeah
next time you go to McDonald's you're
gonna get this mm-hmm I'll do it
all that egg white delight I'm always
down for like a good breakfast sandwich
yeah and I like egg white and I like
that they made this rhyme you know you
can get in the morning makes you feel
good when you were there only four
percent of people on the quiz voted for
this as a favorite it's just the egg
white cheese and ham um it kind of lives
up to its boring visual appeal it's very
bland yeah I'm gonna pass on this one I
say that way these at least I like the
bread like I'm okay with this I'm real
okay with me that's okay second choice I
mean if they don't have a sausage - oh
yeah I'm done with the egg white when I
order this instead of a regular McMuffin
no overall it's not horrible but I can
see why this is the least favorite this
is the mushroom and swiss buttermilk
crispy chicken or any mushrooms
no you're so happy I think this is
basically just the same thing as the
burger but in chicken form yeah also I
feel like just mushrooms with chicken is
an odd pairing yeah I could see it with
no chicken I would say this one looks a
little nicer than the burger did the
chicken is very tiring Giller mm-hmm
what I will say is that this chicken
looks very old like I've never seen a
piece of chicken grab either
yo and this bun is actually pretty solid
gonna feel like brioche that was all
[Music]
this one down yeah I mean it's got
mushrooms on it
Nixon kind of like overpowers everything
yeah I love the chicken but then there's
just that little taste of mushroom
mushroom and onions on top of some it's
not bad this is the least favorite
because you are afraid to order it I
don't think the other thing is a whisper
because it will try this nasty I think
it's the mushroom was it kind of mm-hmm
yeah to be honest I didn't know they
sold up no reason cook yeah I knew they
had the chocolate chip yeah I didn't
know there was a variety to choose from
I think I'm a little biased in this
category because I think oatmeal raisin
cookies are a waste of space only one
percent of people said that oatmeal
raisin cookies were their favorite flex
ain't pineapple on pizza is that a level
that's the best
hmm oh here Cheers
[Music]
I can see why to these favors now it's
not bad but usually the McDonald cookies
are soft I don't really taste the open
you know so it just feels like a regular
chocolate chick to eat without the top
of it that's not bad
not felt like that but there's weight
that oh hell yeah
that's sad I feel bad that this is not a
popular item that's great
okay pretty good I mean I still stand by
what I said about that chocolate chip
cookies are better for like yeah these
are good mm-hmm very impressed we're
done we did it
yeah laughing yes overall a solid
overall solid I think people should
actually give them a try I think the
mushroom sandwiches with least favorite
because nobody is trying to pressure
cookie was good he's good yeah the rest
I would not order I'm just gonna be
honest I would not order the rest not
the first second or third but on your
fourth Friday you'll have room to try I
mean say you go there they don't got
burgers they don't got they don't go for
that mushroom chicken sandwich you know
I'm saying
we had some pleasant surprises today I
think McDonald's has not let us down
thank you McDonald you've been there
bottom of the barrel I'm pretty good
[Music]